según un informe de The New York Times
se han publicado documentos clasificados
sobre la guerra en Ucrania en varias
redes sociales esos documentos detallan
los planes secretos estadounidenses y de
la otan para la asistencia militar a
Ucrania el pentágono ha abierto una
investigación sobre la filtración pero
por ahora hay más preguntas que
respuestas
lo misterioso de estos documentos es que
parecen Auténticos pero al mismo tiempo
algunas partes han sido manipuladas por
lo que no sabemos realmente cómo se
filtraron desde Qué institución de qué
lado se filtraron
el medio informa de que los documentos
clasificados aparecieron por primera vez
en el sitio web de imágenes for Chen y
antes de eso en un grupo de discusión de
videojuegos en Minecraft discord server
antes de ser ampliamente compartidos en
Telegram un investigador del medio
bellinghat ha estado rastreando la
cronología de las filtraciones los
primeros El documento se compartieron
los días 1 y 2 de marzo antes de volver
a publicarse el 5 de abril en 4chan y en
canales de Telegram
funcionarios ucranianos han culpado
directamente a Moscú afirmando que los
documentos contenían una gran cantidad
de información ficticia y presentaban
las características de una operación de
desinformación rusa con el objetivo de
sembrar la discordia entre Ucrania y sus
aliados
Rusia Está tratando de influir en la
sociedad ucraniana con información y
sembrar el miedo el pánico la
desconfianza y la duda es un
comportamiento muy típico de Rusia Son
elementos estándar de los juegos
operativos de la inteligencia rusa y
nada más Mientras tanto funcionarios
estadounidenses han estado trabajando
para que se borren los mensajes de las
redes sociales ante la preocupación de
que una filtración de inteligencia de
este nivel pueda perjudicar el futuro
intercambio de inteligencia entre
Estados Unidos y